So Jamal, what made you choose this bank to open an account?
Well, I've heard a lot of good things about this bank.
And I don't live too far from here,...
...so it's pretty convenient for me.
Good, good. Okay, let's get you started.
So what type of account would you like to open?
A savings or a checking account?
I don't know.
Doesn't matter to me.
Well, I was thinking of opening a checking account.
But I'm not sure what the difference is between that or savings account.
Well Jamal, a checking account is an account used to deposit money at a bank.
Money can be added or removed from the account by visiting the bank or writing a check.
If the account earns interest, it's usually at a lower rate than a savings account.
A savings account is an account you have...
...for the purpose of saving money over a period of time.
Only you can take out money you put into your savings account.